لا حديثه في الاوساط التركيه سوى عن
الانتخابات الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه المقبله
التي يتطلع اليها الاتراك والعالم على حد
سواء بترقب كبير ارتباط اسم تركيا بالعديد
من الملفات الخارجيه يجعل المجتمع الدولي
ينتظر ما ستصفر عنه هذه الانتخابات فكيف
يستعد اردوغان الى هذه المعركه التي
اعترفت المعارضه ان ترشح لها او اعتبرت
المعارضه ان ترشحه لها هو مخالف للدستور
الحكومه التركيه بقياده اردوغان وقبل اشهر
من الانتخابات
اجراءات لاستماله الناخبين تقول صحيفه
واشنطن بوست الامريكيه نقلا عنعارضا اواخر
ديسمبر الماضيه رفع اردوغان الحد الادنى
للاجور بنسبه
55% لم تكن هذه الخطوه الاولى من نوعها
قبل مده ليست بالبعيده اقرت الحكومه برامج
لتقديم الدعم النقدي للاسر ذات الدخل
المنخفض فضلا عن التمويل الذي تم تق دي
حمايه الودائع بالعمله المحليه منخفاض
قيمتها معارض اردوغان يوجهون له ايضا تهمه
محاوله ابعاد السياسيين باستخدام سلاح
المتابعه القضائيه ابرز هذه المتابعات
الحكم على رئيس مدينه اسطنبول رئيس
البلديه اكرم امام اوغلو بالسجن سنتين
وسبعه اشهر مع حضره من ممارسه الانشطه
السياسيه بتهمه اهانه مسؤولين وترى
المعارضه ان هذا الحكم جاء لاقصاء امام
اخلو من الانتخابات خاصه وانه بات يملك
شعبيه كبيره في البلاد وكان اغلو المنتمي
لحزب الشعب الجمهوري قد نجح في الالحاق
هزيمه قاسيه بحزب العداله والتنميه سنه
2019 بفوزه على مرشحه واقتنعس منصب رئيس
بلديه اسطنبول
ارى ان هناك خلافا داخل الطاوله السداسيه
ولن يخرج بنتائج ايجابيه يعني هناك عده
خيارات داخل طويله سداسيه من سوريا واش
اكرم امام اوغلو وكمال اوغلو وهو في مقدمه
المرشحين برايي ان ثلاثتهما لا يستطيعون
منافسه اردوغان
لا يوجد لديهم مرشح رويدا رويدا بدات
الخلافات تظهر بينهم لا يوجد بينهم منافس
لارضوان
على الاقل حيث انها لم تستقر بعد على
مرشحها مما يثير تكه هناك عن امكانيه وجود
انقسامات داخليه من شانها ان تشتت
مجهودتها بعيدا عن المنافسه مع المعارضه
فان حظو الرئيس التركي قد تتاثر ايضا
بملفات اخرى لا سيما بعد خسارته بعد
المعارك الاقتصاديه بسبب قراراته انت اثرت
على الوضع الداخلي للبلاد من بين ابرز
النقاط السلبيه التي برزت التراجع الكبير
لقيمه العمله المحليه التي فقدت نحو ثلثي
قيمتها مقابل الدولار في العامين الماضين
اقتصاديا بلغ التضخم على اساس سنوي نحو
85% في نوفمبر الماضي في اعلى نسبه تسجل
في تركيا منذ اكثر من 25 عاما